so to some degree things are not going
particularly well for the trump family
right now i mean they're still rich
or and they're still privileged and
they're still powerful but there are
criminal investigations going on
into their businesses trump's social
media reach has been replaced by
a blog that nobody reads etc
and now eric trump and donald trump jr
two of donald trump's kids are doing a
sort of pity me
pity us media tour and it's just
hilarious
and pathetic i don't know that i've ever
seen a family that is so
privileged constantly claimed to be the
biggest
victims of everything and everyone
and i think it all comes down from trump
trump regularly claiming i've nobody's
been treated as unfairly as me and
so check check out some of these clips
here is eric trump last night
on sean hannity's fox news propaganda
show and in this clip
eric trump whines we just get all these
subpoenas and they're treating us so
terribly and then he just starts telling
lies
see if you can pick up on the lies and i
know that his mouth moving is a signal
that he's lying but
there's a specific lie that he tells
here investigating his zero experienced
son being paid millions
and all of these other instances now
where he's been caught red-handed
lying about knowing anything about
hunter's foreign business dealings
sean i agree completely listen i'm on
the receiving end of every single day my
father gets subpoena after subpoena we
do as a family
they attack us they go after us for
doing absolutely nothing wrong we gave
up business when my father went to the
white house
they did the exact opposite when joe
biden became vice president hunter
biden got into business but yet every
single day my family is attacked
and they look for any comma that's out
of place and the prosecutorial
misconduct in this country is out of
control
but yet because we're republicans they
attack us and they do absolutely nothing
to the other side
yeah so pity me pity us but he says we
gave up our business
when trump became president no you
didn't
donald trump made 1.6 billion dollars
during his four years as president from
his private businesses
ivanka and jared kushner
made hundreds of millions i believe it
was 640 million
if i recall correctly from the family
business what are you talking about
they literally opened the trump dc hotel
blocks from the white house
while trump was running for president in
2016 and then as soon as trump was
inaugurated
foreign leaders would come to trump's dc
hotel and stay there
when they would go visit trump or visit
other diplomats or american officials
in order to ingratiate themselves with
the trump white house what kind of
fantasy world is this guy living in that
not only
he portrays himself as a huge victim he
also just tells lies about the things
that they've done and not done
then last night it wasn't just eric
trump with sean hannity
it was also donald trump jr with um
tucker carlson on fox news and in this
clip don jr says hey
the fact that my dad is being
investigated
this is what you expect in so-called
banana republics not
in the united states more but if this
was going on in the banana republic we'd
be outraged
when it's going on in one of the largest
states in america
everyone seems to be silent on it and so
there's two things here first of all is
it not possible for don jr
to make a political point without using
a pejorative term about other countries
like i
i'm not saying banana republic is like
the n word banana republic
it describes a country that's less
developed with political instability
often an economy that depends on
exporting
one thing like a banana or a particular
mineral a con a rare earth mineral a
conflict mineral whatever the case may
be so
it's not the n word it's not calling a
jewish person the k word don't get me
wrong but
it's a pejorative it's a derogatory term
and
you know he just can't seem to make any
statement
without kind of using a gross term about
someone or some other country
but the funny thing about the
comparisons to developing nations
is that the the real analogy between
trump
and developing nations is the one we
made during the trump era which is
trump's authoritarianism trump's disdain
for freedom of the press trump's comfort
with cronyism
and nepotism and corruption and slush
funds and all of this stuff
that's what we are used to seeing
in the corrupt countries of the
developing world
often run by authoritarians or even
authoritarian more developed nations you
get the picture so
there is they they seem to stumble
across
the fact that there are things happening
here
that have an analogy in other parts of
the world
but they just get the analogy completely
wrong it's not the investigation of
trump
that makes us like a so-called banana
republic it was trump
as an authoritarian buffoon as president
that made us like all of these other
countries whose leaders
trump admired by the way people like
duterte and kim jong-un and putin and
the others in any case
eric and don jr making the rounds
claiming to be victims
and if anybody gets charged in these
probes i mean listen
if the manhattan d.a charges somebody
trump or other
trump associates if the new york ag
probe leads to charges
we have so much of this insanity to look
forward to if there are any charges
brought in those investigations it will
be these two
don jr and eric completely unmoored from
reality
claiming everybody's just being so mean
and unfair and everything's just a a
scam endo a witch hunt
they stole everything they could while
in the white house they stripped the
country
down to the studs and now they're saying
we did everything right
and they won't leave daddy alone in some
sense
they're not used to facing consequences
so it probably is very confusing because
of the attention
that trump brought on himself by running
for president and becoming president
the charity was investigated and
ultimately had to pay a fine and be shut
down
now there are multiple investigations
they just don't like their actions
having consequences for a long time
trump wasn't sconced up
in trump tower in his office or
penthouse or whatever and people were
paying attention to him but not like
they started to when he ran for
president
and uh even losing the presidency
after having arguably the most
disastrous presidential term in modern
political history
that's a consequence and they're simply
not used to that
they're used to being the bullies and
there may now actually be some
consequences
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video